hey guys it's gary vaynerchuk and today
I want to talk about something that's
not super complicated it's not going to
be a very long video but I set an
interview today and really hit everybody
on the call pretty hard and I think it's
pretty important to understand the
statement was I said that social media
to me is a stake and to most people in
the business world today 99% of them
it's pepper and I guess what i mean by
that is i just don't think that this
whole movement whether you want to call
it social media because oh by the way it
was called web two point oh three
minutes ago you know i don't care what
you call it but not understanding that
there is now a platform that is superior
and dramatically more powerful than the
television or print or radio it is a
massive mistake and reason I've been
successful in it at some level whether
you think that or not or you think that
depending on your view of things the
reason I think I've been able to build
brand equity and build businesses on
this platform is that I truly believe
the social web the one that requires
interaction the one that requires people
that have some status like myself to not
think of themselves as big [ __ ] but
actually care is very important and I
think that the reason I've been able to
get results and make things happen is
because I think of all of this as the
stake the main meal and not a nuance
like pepper this isn't sprinkling this
needs to be agenda this isn't something
you carve out of your small budget and
give ten thousand dollars to to play
this is the game this is the stake not
the pepper